jacques nichet sûrs et bonsoir
alors jacques michel un jour vous êtes
réveillé dans un lieu que vous ne
connaissiez pas vous souveniez de rien
votre nom votre prénom votre adresse
votre femme et vos enfants vos amis et
en plus vous ne savez même pas ce
qu'était l'amitié l'amour la peur bref
vous aviez le cerveau complètement vide
oui et à 30 ans comme un nouveau né vous
avez dû tout reprendre à zéro vous nous
raconterez votre histoire à 20 heures
[Musique]
jacques michel sûrs et re bonsoir alors
contrairement à usage je ne vais pas
commencer par votre première naissance
mais par votre deuxième naissance nous
sommes au mois de juin il fait beau vous
vous réveillez seul sur un banc au
milieu d'une grande place bondée de
monde vous tentez de mettre en marche
votre mémoire rien votre cerveau est
vide incapables de réfléchir en face de
vous vous reconnaissez l'opéra de paris
vous touchez votre visage et vous dites
je n'ai pas l'air jeune je n'ai pas
l'air vieux et à votre doigt vous
découvrez une alliance et vous vous
dites alors j'ai une femme
j'avais devant moi quand je me suis
réveillé un brouillard le brouillard
s'est dissipée j'ai vu l'opéra avec
c'était l'opéra donc je savais l'opéra
c'est paris n'a pas de soucis mais la
brume est séparé de ma tête je me disais
qu'un rêve rêve c'est pas grave je me
réveillais vous constatez à ce moment là
que vous portez un manteau rouge avec 60
francs dans une poche un pantalon et des
chaussons d'intérieur et vous dites je
dois habitait juste à côté si je suis en
chaussons ah bah oui mais pour moi
c'était l'évidence fit d'ailleurs je
repère une cabine téléphonique à côté si
ça se trouve je suis juste sorti pour
téléphoner ou pour un tendre coup de
téléphone quelqu'un m'appelait faut que
je reste alors à côté de vous il ya un
petit sac en plastique et à l'intérieur
il ya une cordelette un quignon de pain
un ticket de métro une carte de paris
quand tu es la carte gd si j'ai si j'ai
une carte de paris jeudi au parisien
alors là vous décidé de quitter notre
banc pour déambuler dans les rues de
paris vous crever de faim vous avez 60
francs mais vous ne faites pas le lien
argent h à manger qu'un je suis rentré
dans un petit supermarché qui était pas
très loin du banc que j'étais d'ailleurs
et j'ai mangé dans les rayons et ce qui
est
étrange c'est que je savais très bien
que je faisais mal mais je savais ce que
c'était que de voler alors en fait ce
lien argent h à manger vous reviendra au
cours de notre errance dans paris quand
un serveur dans un café vous demandera
de payer un chocolat chaud alors une
nuit nous entends des contrôles
d'identité les policiers vous bourde
coups de pied vous fuyez ils finiront
par vous arrêter après une très longue
course-poursuite vous planquer sous une
bagnole et ils vous disent tu nous a
fait courir fuyez 1 et là vous êtes né
en garde à vue mais en garde à vue vous
avez rien à dire on vous demande de
signer votre déposition n'y a rien dans
la déposition on vous emmène à l'hôpital
psychiatrique sainte anne dans le 14e
arrondissement de paris et là on
découvre un énorme hématome qui va de la
nuque à l'épaule oui mais quand même
c'est 20 cm de long j'étais bien marqué
sur le premier à marquer ensuite on vous
fait visiter l'hôpital à ce moment là
vous pensez quoi vous pensez que j'étais
fou je pensais que j'étais dans un
milieu de fou hein et vous vous
considérez pas comme un fou à le non jeu
j'avais juste un problème c'est tout
mais j'étais pas fou aura pour tout le
monde vous êtes monsieur x dans cet
hôpital sainte-anne c'est à dire que
quand on appelait les gens pour venir
prendre les médicaments on appeler jean
pierre on après françois et ils avaient
leur petite étiquette sur leur cover de
médicaments et moi c'était lynch un
médecin m'a dit non non c'est bon c'est
pas grave on va t'appeler x x à existe
hier jacky ickx et moi même en tant que
professeur de l'hôpital je m'appelle
j'ai alors voulu dit il ya quatre jours
que je suis là pourquoi je vous ai pas
encore vu les mecs vous répondre mais ça
fait 15 jours que vous êtes là vous
rendez compte vous n'avez pas non plus
mention d'autres
hélas ils vous révèlent le nom de votre
mal l'amnésie mais là je lui demande
comment ça soit long 1 elle a une vie
faut le temps plus faut du temps
le temps déjà continué chape je passe je
passe quatre jours tu me dis tiens à
15,9 alors combien de temps pour ça
lorsqu'il dit là il dit que
effectivement l'hématome
témoigne peut-être si l'agression
mais on n'en sait rien jusque là non
alors le problème c'est que ses
entretiens avec le docteur gones à rien
et c'est là qu'ils vous proposent de
prendre du pain totale c'est-à-dire du
sérum de vérité mais ça fonctionne pas
il dit inquiète pas tune tu vas
t'endormir gentiment tu suis moi vois
mon réveil tu vas pas de souvenir de ce
qu'on a fait ensemble et je vais
enregistrer et je vais écrire tout ça tu
auras toutes les données et au réveil
j'ai vu une personne de moi déconfite
ouais il n'est pas content parce que ça
y est voilà ça n'a pas marché alors
après le troisième shoot avec une dose
augmenté de penthotal au réveil là il a
un large sourire 1 il avait tant
qu'acteur c'est parce qu à une question
sur l'amitié vous avez répondu charlelie
charlie alain carré vélizy et charlélie
couture évidemment il prend contact avec
charlélie couture vous le rencontriez et
s'est pointé quand vous rencontrez
charlelie dit mais bien sûr que je te
connais grand con
mais il m'a pris dans ses bras avant que
ce pleure quand il m'a vu pleurer il m'a
serré il m'a dit t'inquiète pas c'est
bon je suis là c'est bon c'est bon on a
fait les 400 coups ensemble voilà fera
visiter leur fait aux beaux-arts de
nancy j'étais au bord des noms si vous
n'êtes pas mal fringuée ensemble cherche
un braquage
alors là il vous promet de vous aider
effectivement il vous dit en fait pas je
suis là et tout et puis un jour vous
êtes en train de dessiner un infirmier
entre dans la pièce et il lui dit
jacques michel pose tes crayons vous
réalisez que c'est vrai ça vous donc
vous comprenez que vous êtes jacques
nichet n'était pas sûr quand il m'a
appelé jacques michel et qui m'a dit
c'est ton nom chez lequel
déjà que vous sachiez comment donc il
serront prénom complet avant
c'est incroyable s'est il alors ensuite
l'infirmier dit jacques michel le
docteur t'attend en état famille quand
vous arrivez ils disent tu t'appelles
jacques michel sûrs et je te présente t
par an et ta femme martine vous rien je
suis devant des étrangers voilà j'ai vu
quand même dans ce couple de personnes
plus âgées
la tristesse de l' angoisse de l'accord
et puis la petite femme qui était là les
sympathiques n'était jolie comme tout
elle est venue timidement vers moi et
pour me dire je suis ta femme chez
martine en touchant à peine et dans ses
yeux oui j'ai vu qu' il y avait même si
oui alors lamartine sort un album photo
de son sac elle dit voilà ça c'est
sandrine ta fille ça c'est pierre henry
ton fils et vous ça vous laisse
complètement indifférent non mais qu'est
ce que c'est que t'es pas qui c'est un
truc quoi c'est c'est faux là vous vous
dites on m'a retrouvé mais je ne me suis
jamais senti autant perdu mari vous
rentrez chez vous quand vous arrivez
chez vous vous rencontré votre fils qui
a un an vous dites nous sommes de
nouveau nés et vous n'avez aucune
tendresse pour votre fils vous avez nom
pareil la main qui sont sans pareils
votre fille sandrine
stallergenes vous embrasse pas qu'on
voulait l'embrasser à une espèce de
mouvement de recul oui il faut dire que
j'étais également très déformée
apparemment par les médicaments alors il
ya une scène extraordinaire c'est que le
soir dans la chambre vous êtes allongé
donc à côté de cette femme que vous ne
connaissez pas martin vous constatez qu
elle vous fait de l'effet quand même
j'étais pas amnésiques de partout quoi
alors vous voulez lui faire l'amour
ouais mais vous savez plus comment faire
vous êtes comme un puceau un jeu josé
josé pomme déshabiller c'est martin gady
déshabille-toi martine elle prend les
choses en main
tout prix et vous faites l'amour avec
martine coach était la première fois
c'était génial je verrais bien que ça
recommence
et lamartine nous raconte vos origines
votre rencontre à tous les deux votre
amour vos enfants enfin votre vie est en
fait elle vous apprend qu'un soir elle
nous a demandé de rentrer la voiture
dans le garage vous ai fait une mauvaise
rencontre j'ai pris un coup sur la tête
apparemment c'est ce que c'est les 3
jours de black out total on ne sait pas
avec martine vue décidé de vous lancer à
nouveau dans l'aventuré de la paternité
de faire un troisième enfant c'est
martin un jour qui m'a dit bon on va
aller de l'avant maintenant ça suffit
regardez moi dans les yeux elle me dit
qu'est ce que tu vois dans mes yeux et
regarde bien
il me dit tu vois pas qui a de l'amour
je suis dit si ça y ressemble quand même
elle me dit tu vois dans les tiens je
suis en train de regarder je vois la
même chose et avec l'amour on va faire
un troisième enfant et cet enfant va
l'aimer et ça sera l'enfant qui nous
réunira complètement ton truc de
paternité tu va le retrouver il l'a
quand vous allez voir l'échographie il
ya un miracle quoi vous aimez l'enfant
qui est dans le ventre de votre vous
retrouver l'amour sur cetet l'ordination
magnifique histoire
hélas comme l'échographie voyez votre
enfant de troisième enfant dans le
ventre de sa mère voulait mais est
bientôt cet amour s'étendra à vos deux
premiers enfants bien sûr alors vous
chercher du boulot et un jour vous
prenez un carton plein de deux reliques
et les feuilles de paye à des diplômes
enfin tout ça vous allez l anpe et la
fille contre toute attente vous dit j'ai
du boulot pour vous formidable mais en
fait vous êtes architecte
et qu'on vous commencé à bosser et que
votre patron vous montre les plans d'une
ancienne préfecture à rénover voilà
c'est un miracle là c'est le miracle
comme un film c'est que vous voyez les
choses en trois dimensions voyez cela il
ya les images se construire pour devenir
architecte parce que vous étiez avant
évidemment c'est les interrupteurs qui
s'allument au final voilà c'est ça alors
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que vous
recommencez une carrière à succès dans
l'architecturé alors s'éclater alors
maintenant on va faire l'interview comme
je la fais d'habitude c'est à dire en
commençant par le début alors si vous
n'aviez pas été amenés vie que je vous
aurais accueillant 10 ans alors jacques
nichet durée vous êtes né le 17 décembre
1957 à nancy perd cadre à l'urssaf mère
couturière voilà on aurait fait une
interview dans le sens normal et jingle
mobilier et jim voilà la boucle et libe
merci de votre témoignage
merci
formidable histoire les ans les enfants
ont dit une fois
mais papa août et
tape out et
ont fait répéter que
son père était à m merci de votre
témoignage et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous y
mettez un pouce bleus